filles en laye bonjour nous sommes en
direct aujourd'hui pour vous faire vivre
un peu la rentrée de du foot
international du foot européen des clubs
avec le tirage au sort de la ligue des
champions on va savoir quelles vont être
les adversaires du psg et de marseille
les deux clubs dans la compétition et
pour parler de ce tirage au sort chaque
série kelly bonjour bonsoir cédric
bonjour vincent j'espère que vous allez
bien on va vivre avec vous ce tirage au
sort alors j'ai un ordinateur devant moi
parce que comme d'habitude on n'a pas le
droit de vous diffuser ces images
puisqu'elles sont la propriété d'un de
nos concurrents mais on va quand même
vous faire vivre ça on va vous n'hésitez
pas à vous à nous poser vos questions on
va analyser un peu le tirage ça va être
très sympa on à ryan qui nous a rejoint
dirait dans le chat qui nous dit go
voilà n'auront on démarre vous êtes déjà
plus une centaine à nous suivre
vous n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions
on va parler un peu de cette cérémonie
qui vient de débuter gelé sous les yeux
en général ça prend un peu de temps à
démarrer ce genre de séries générales il
ya beaucoup de blabla beaucoup d'image
voilà je pense qu'on aura les la
première boule après 6h30 à mon avis
voilà à peu près dans un gros quart
d'heure on espère en tout cas on va
peut-être parler des chapeaux et déjà
expliquer un peu comment ça marche un
tirage au sort de ligue des champions eh
bien écoutez vous avez 4 4 chapeaux qui
sont déterminées selon le lun 10 des
clubs et pas uniquement puisque vous
avez la ligne traque de francfort qui a
gagné la ligue europa la saison dernière
qui se retrouve dans le chapeau 1 il y a
aussi dans le chapeau 1 je crois les
champions des principaux des principaux
championnats c'est facile ils sont
affichés en face de nous on va écouter
donc c'est voilà donc il ya tout un
règlement et ensuite il essaie de
répartir aussi pour éviter d'avoir des
des pays d'être aux deux pays dans
différents chapeaux donc
voilà on voit le paris saint germain qui
est dans le chapeau 1 et l'olympique de
marseille dans le chapeau 4 oeuf oui
avec donc on disait des règles très
spécifique aussi concernant les droits
télé on va dire pour pas qu'il y ait
plusieurs clubs du même pays dans le
même groupe déjà et il faut qu'il soit
suffisamment répartis pour pouvoir
offrir aux différents spectateurs du
spectacle un peu le mardi et le mercredi
selon ce sont les horaires alors que
hamit altintop vient d'arriver sur le
plateau de l'uefa qui a apporté le
trophée ancien joueur de galatasaray du
balat de munich je vous rappelle qu'on
ne peut pas vous diffuser ces images
dizaine dit nous vous dans les
commentaires ce que vous voulez pour le
psg alors parce que quand même
maintenant on aura là dit on aura ça va
que démarrer vers 18h30 on s'attend à
peu près une demi heure de tirage tout
ça prend du temps quand même puis ya un
peu des pauses puis il faut quand même
dire voilà le real de madrid a gagné on
va leur faire une petite cérémonie un
peu gentillette
le psg chapeau 1 allez on va commencer
peut être par là c'est quoi le meilleur
et le pire tirage alors de mon point de
vue le meilleur tirage alors je vais
peut-être un peu je pense que pour le
paris saint-germain l'idéal ce serait
pas forcément un tirage où on récupère
l'adversaire le moins coté du chapeau 2
chapeau 3 chapeau 4 moi j'aurais
tendance à penser que le paris
saint-germain il lui faut la meilleure
équipe possible du chapeau 2 pour
s'étalonner pour se jauger donc voilà à
partir de là on pourrait penser que ça
pourrait être liverpool ou chelsea
par contre le danger c'est le chapeau 3
là je pense vraiment que le chapeau 3 si
le psg veut être un petit peu tranquille
c'est quand même mieux d'avoir une
équipe peut-être comme le sporting comme
donesk plutôt que d'avoir l'inter de
milan où dortmund donc ça serait ça sera
sans doute plus intéressant après le
chapeau 4 très honnêtement on va bon
faut pas se mentir le chapeau 4 le psg
il n'ya pas une seule équipe à craindre
dans le chapeau 4 le maccabi haïfa
maccabi haifa cd mauvais souvenir pour
le psg mais ça remonte tellement loin
c'était même avant même la leyre le
début de l'ère qatarie au psg donc non
il ya surtout surtout le psg qu'on voit
depuis le début de la saison mais moi
j'aurai envie vraiment j'aurais envie
que de ce chapeau 2 sorte un bel
adversaire anglais ça me ça ça me
plairait bien alors celle ci avec le
côté toujours thomass tourelles ça peut
toujours être sympathique où liverpool
parce que quand même finaliste de la
saison dernière donc c'est sexy c'est
une belle affiche
voilà si on peut éviter je regarde un
peu dans le chapeau 2 si on peut éviter
leipzig bon ça moi personnellement ça me
fait pas rêver donc
effectivement alors là pas mal de
questions qui concernent à la fois le
tirage au sort des ligues des champions
et pas que bovard équipement est ce que
c'est enfin la bonne année pour paris
c'est le comment dire le serpent de mer
qui revient bon sur ce qu'on voit sur ce
début de saison si le paris
saint-germain parvient à garder un petit
peu cet état d'esprit ce collectif si
galtier continue à bien tenir ses
troupes comme depuis début de la saison
c'est sûr que le paris saint germain
sera un candidat à la finale du 10 juin
maintenant des gens on va voir avec ce
tirage parce qu'il peut y avoir on a
parlé du meilleur tirage possible
maintenant le psg ça peut être un tirage
si c'est liverpool si c'est l'inter de
milan et si c'est
peut-être les glasgow rangers ce ou le
celtic de glasgow on va pas dire que le
psg va se faire éliminé dès la phase de
groupes mais
d'ailleurs il n'y aura pas de pas de
droit à l'erreur donc on va déjà voir un
petit peu là comment ça va se passer il
faut bien voir aussi que finir premier
du groupe aura son incidence puisque la
règle maintenant il ya plus cette règle
du but à l'extérieur ce qui donne à mon
sens quand même un vrai avantage à
l'équipe qui recevra au retour peut-être
encore plus qu'avant donc je pense que
le psg aura tout intérêt à finir premier
pour s'ouvrir la
un beau chemin en 8e oui on espère
effectivement pour essayer d'aller
d'aller loin de d'avancé sparta qui nous
parlent pas forcément ligue des
champions mais vous n'hésitez pas à
poser des questions voix sur football
parce que là on parlait de paris on va
parler de l'om sparta qui me dit faut-il
croire à ronaldo à l'om pour leur faire
disputer les gens mais parce que ronaldo
ne disputera pas la ligue des champions
à manchester et s'ils veulent discuter
s'il va à marseille la dispute bah
écoutez tout le monde en parle tout le
monde a un avis c'est absolument magique
alors pour l'instant ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'en termes d'un faux a
priori il ya pas grand chose un a priori
on est on est même pas sûr nous d'un
intérêt de l'olympique de marseille pour
ronaldo enfin un intérêt bien évidemment
je pense qui cracherait pas dessus mais
mais de vraies discussions d'une vraie
volonté du club de faire venir cristiano
à marseille pour l'instant ça nous on
n'a aucune information aucune certitude
c'est vraiment parti d'un hashtag et de
de la volonté de djibril cissé par
exemple en fin d'un rêve
après dun quand on y réfléchit bien moi
je m'imagine cristiano ronaldo qui va
regarder ce soir un petit peu le tirage
au sort qui va regarder peut-être les
éventuels adversaires de l'om et de se
dire si l'om tombe pas dans un groupe
de la mort comme on a l'habitude de le
dire peut-être que ça peut le faire
réfléchir après moi il ya l'aspect
financier qui me semble rédhibitoire
mais enfin bon si si cristiano était
prêt à faire un petit effort à diminuer
ses émoluments si l'om trouve un pass
pass bon on voit bien on voit bien
barcelone qui a dépensé sur 58 millions
d'euros cet été alors qu'il était censé
ne plus avoir un 1 euro donc écouté tout
est financièrement on se dit tout est
toujours possible même s'il faut faire
très attention à ce que l'om est dans le
viseur de l'uefa donc il faudra pas
refaire n'importe quoi ça fait rêver ça
fait et puis franchement ça fait du bien
de rêver un petit peu donc pourquoi pas
personnellement j'y crois pas mais
pourquoi pas après alexis sanchez voilà
notre calibre on a des bras mis une
petite star ah bah oui alexis sanchez
bon faut voir ce qui là encore
sous le capot parce que bon la saison
dernière l'inter de milan il a pas il
n'a pas joué beaucoup c'est certain que
alexis sanchez ronaldo en attaque
il ya six ou sept ans
même peut-être même un peu moins jeunes
est un peu je suis un peu pessimiste il
ya quatre ou cinq ans sur fifa manette
en main ça se jouait sa levée de fonds
dès c'est sûr alors la cérémonie
continue et bien évidemment et on n'a
toujours pas tiré au sort qui va arriver
d'ici quelques instants on va peut-être
parler de l'olympique de marseille
justement l'olympique de marseille
qu'est ce que ce serait quoi en fait le
pire et le meilleur tirage pour la ville
de marseille alors le pire tirage bah
écoute et déjà je pense que le real de
madrid je pense que dans le chapeau 1
bon il ya manchester city aussi mais
vraiment vraiment le real je pense que
le tenant du titre il vaut mieux il vaut
mieux l'éviter
et puis
le problème en plus si vous avez le real
de madrid c'est que derrière un chapeau
2 vous avez liverpool et chelsea
puisqu'ils ne peut pas y avoir deux deux
clubs d'un même pays donc la limite si
vous prenez manchester city dans le
chapeau 1 l'avantagé c'est que déjà vous
éviter chelsea liverpool dans le chapeau
2 après ça peut créer des décalages des
choses comme ça donc moi un assemblage
real de madrid liverpool et puis une
terre de milan
ça va rappeler des mauvais souvenirs à
l'om
ça va rappeler un zéro pointé quand il
avait eu arsenal hors nationale naples
et dortmund donc
ça serait le pire du pire effectivement
on va voir on va attendre et le meilleur
tirage dans le chapeau 1 j'ai quand même
l'impression que la bonne option ce
serait francfort où l'ajax peut-être ça
peut-être l'ajax faut toujours se méfier
parce qu'ils sont toujours des jeunes
est où maintenant c'est vrai qu'ils ont
été comme d'habitude un peuplier piller
cet été ils ont perdu grave nbr ils ont
perdu à l'air ils ont dévoré lisandro
martinez qui est parti à manchester
united schürch aussi enfin ils ont perdu
beaucoup de beaucoup de joueurs
maintenant ils ont cette capacité l'ajax
assez phénoménale à se régénérer à une
vitesse grand v donc il faudra se méfier
il y apporte aussi qu'on a quelqu'un
perdu vite ignore milieu de terrain qui
a perdu du lourd aussi vieira qui est
parti à arsenal donc porto bon ils ont
l'air d'avoir fait un bon début de
saison championnat portugais donc avoir
à avoir line traque de frankfort ouais
c'est une équipe joueuse pour marseille
ça peut être plutôt assez sympa c'est
forcément une de ces trois-là v pour une
fois le lot chapeau 1 offre des
possibilités à l'om comme c'est pas le
genre il ya juste une boule à tirer et à
peut-être deux ou trois comme c'est
bizarre parce qu'on se rend compte
finalement que dans le chapeau 2 parfois
il n'y a pas beaucoup de bons tirages
par contre dans le chapeau 2 non à dans
le chapeau 2 ouais si vous regardez un
petit peu leur à dire qu'il est le
meilleur à prendre c'est peut-être
lipsyc houleux ou le fc séville encore
donc sévi ça reste toujours une équipe
sur le plan européen qui est solide
je les ai sortis l'an dernier mais pas
facilement donc mais c'est vrai que le
chapeau 2 offre moins de
on va dire que le chapeau 1 vous avez
vraiment le pire du pire et puis ça va
quoi le chapeau 2 c'est plus resserrée
entre le pire du pire est le moins pire
c'est pas trés pas très beau ce que je
dis mais mais vous avez compris l'idée
il n'y a pas une énorme gap aussi
important aussi énorme effectivement
alors que pour l'instant la cérémonie de
l'uefa je vous fais un petit point de ce
qui se passe on est en train d'expliquer
les règles du tirage dans ce qu'on vous
disait une équipe de chaque chapeau dans
chaque groupe puis ensuite on fait
attention à ce qu'il n'ait pas d'
équipes du même pays dans chaque groupe
mais aussi quand une équipe tombe dans
le dos abcd d'un pays l'autre club le
prochain d'après l'équipe du pays
arrivera dans le groupe e f g h voilà
c'est à peu près car mon explication
j'espère pour vous donc voilà n'hésitez
pas à nous dire un peu ce que vous
pensez de ces tirages je vois que vous
ètes bientôt 200 à nous suivre en tout
cas sur youtube et vous êtes très
nombreux sur le site du figaro donc
voilà le tirage va bientôt commencer on
va bientôt savoir
contre qui va jouer le psg et
l'olympique de marseille va évidemment
est aussi toutes les autres équipes on
s'attend quand même à des petits matches
très sympa entre chapeau un chapeau 2 on
peut tomber sur du real liverpool du
bayern barça ça peut quand même dès le
début avoir des sacrées affiche sourire
bas de façon ces deux essais le but
c'est un peu le sel et surtout que comme
jeu comme je le disais la première place
va peut-être être encore un petit peu
plus important de cette saison donc là
il va y avoir vraiment de belles
confrontations
comme d'habitude on va on va nous
journalistes chercher le groupe de la
mort comme d'habitude entre guillemets y
aura un groupe en bois
on appelle ça comme ça exactement donc
il ya des après il ya des vous avez des
clubs qu'ils sont un peu même si ça
s'est un peu calmé vous avez un club
comme manchester city qui avait
l'habitude d'avoir des tirages au sort
plutôt assez coton et puis vous aviez le
real de madrid avait plutôt l'habitude
d'avoir des tirages au sort où il s'en
tire toujours toujours bien donc là on
va voir si les rides je ne sais pas de
lipstick de données et puis deux
du maccabi haïfa pour encore se dire que
le real a bien voilà donc
effectivement on réellement le sort city
l'an dernier il me semble que c'etait
paris manchester city lab sich et bush
c'était le quatrième voyons tout à fait
vrai voilà c'était les quatre équipes
donc forcément nom de chartis a peut
être compliqué paris aussi à une petite
histoire de deux tirages on va dire un
peu un peu coton ou de coton ils ont par
exemple j'ai pas souvenir du psg alors
il faudrait me remettre tous les tirages
des dernières ça va être compliqué j'ai
pas souvenir que le psg se soit retrouvé
vraiment une fois dans un groupe de la
mort mais ils ont jamais eu non plus des
tirages
simple jamais des tirage extrêmement
difficile mais ils héritent pas souvent
dans le chapeau 3 de l'adversaire le
plus simple pour moi c'est vraiment un
peu pour le psg c'est vraiment ce
chapeau 3 qui va déterminer de là la
difficulté ou pas de ce tirage oui parce
que on tombe contre dortmund ou pour le
compte de chaque tir de donetsk la
confusion est pas du tout la même non
non non là c'est certain vous avez
donesk par exemple malheureux voilà le
contexte international fait que déjà ils
joueront à bartoli ils joueront pas à
domicile
il jurait qu'il est parti voilà ils ont
ils n'ont plus que trois joueurs
étrangers qui avaient l'habitude d'avoir
cinq six brésiliens et tout alors bon
c'est d'un autre côté ça donne la chance
à de jeunes ukrainiens de
de montrer ce qu'ils savent faire mais
bon donnait ce qui a priori dans le
chapeau 3 ça me semblait vraiment
l'équipe l'équipe à prendre et de loin
quoi on ice melt dit psg contre le barça
ce serait magnifique une belle affiche
pour le psg dès le deuxième tour après
le barça ça rappelle aussi des mauvais
souvenirs on va dire ça rappelle de
mauvais souvenirs et puis c'est une
équipe qui sait quand même
considérablement renforcée alors
aujourd'hui il ya quand même bon et déjà
il va falloir qu'ils arrivent à valider
les derniers à leur dernier contrat là
notamment joué le coup donné peut
toujours pas jouer voilà donc ça il va
falloir bon je pense qu'ils vont ils
vont bien et vont bien y arriver quand
même parce que je n'ose pas imaginer une
saison blanche pour jules connait enfin
j'ai même pas comment ça se passerait
dans ces cas là et ce qui en fait y
retournerait au fc séville est ce que le
transfert c'est un nul et j'avoue que
réglementairement j'ai pas j'ai pas
regardé j'ai pas regardé ça maintenant
le barça c'est un peu un épouvantail
parce que c'est vrai que bon quand vous
êtes vous avez déjà robert lewandowski
qui vous rejoins c'est assez facile la
vie est plus facile et puis surtout
après par contre ce qui va pas être
simple c'est pour les amis de mettre ses
enfants parce que quand vous regardez
pour l'instant qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
dégraisser ils veulent faire partir
pierre emerick aubameyang et ou memphis
de paille pour l'instant on est le jeu
mais depuis quelques jours derniers le
26 25 20 25 donc on n'est plus qu'à six
jours de la fin du mercato
si vous les vendez pas et que vous
attaquer la saison avec lewandowski
aubameyang de paille rafinha ferrand
torres en dessous faty
dembélé sa ferme ou si un jour ça fait
voilà c'est un pour trois places je vous
coupe un peu parce que le tirage au sort
vient de débuter mais aaron tir pour
l'instant les premières équipes à l'ajax
d'amsterdam qui étaient tirés dans le
groupe à là c'est le fc porto qui est
tiré je crois que ça va aller dans le
groupe b du coup donc a priori il faut
aller plutôt dans le dans le a et b on a
dit ça me ferait pas sa peau pour
marseille en ivoire est tout à fait là
il faudra les il faudra aller dans ce
dans l'ansé de l'aca serait pas ce
serait pas simple on à vincent duchène
dans les commentaires qu une île
liverpool n alpes et naples dans le
groupe du psg il ya quelques années ça
avait été très compliqué
forcément un contre exemple
surtout que naples à l'époque c'était
autre chose que le naples d'aujourd'hui
qui sera
voilà donc groupe iii serait pas le pire
des tirages même s'il faut se méfier
bons mais ils ont quand même perdu ils
ont perdu coulibaly notamment du parti à
chelsea qui est parti à chelsea donc sa
taille patron de leur défense et tout
ils ont pris un sud coréen kim min-jung
à la place qui a l'air plutôt qui fait
un bon début de saison qui a déjà marqué
un but en série a mais bon c'est pas
koulibaly voilà il ya aussi mène devant
mais ils ont perdu dries mertens qui
était aussi un joueur important
d'expérience c'est un peu alors by me
vient d'être retirée dans le groupe c on
s'arrêtera vraiment quand les premières
équipes tomberont contre d'autres
équipes l'instant voilà on ajuste les
répartitions des gros parce qu'ici c'est
par rapport à ce que vous disiez vincent
ce qui va on va voir dans quel groupe
tombe
le paris saint germain a priori ça va
être donc parce que par rapport à
l'alternance comme on disait entre mardi
et mercredi c'est à dire que marseille
risque de se retrouver
ça serait pas mal ça va être pas mal
d'ailleurs ce que donc la marseille
serait plutôt groupe abc des noms
allemands s'améliorer oui a priori non
mais il y aura des annales jax porte ou
franck forte comme adversaires
potentiels ce qui serait mieux
ça peut ça peut faire des
deux perspectives intéressantes de
munich qui serait aussi un tu rajoutes
qu'on va dire compliqué
la danse est enfin là si si le règlement
on est bon si on parce que c'est
toujours difficile de comprendre les
règlements lui a été bon il ya trois
chances sur quatre d'avoir quand même
l'un d'eux
amsterdam porto francfort donc milan
groupe e on rappelle aussi que non
seulement les règlements de la faa sont
compliquées donc on peut se tromper mais
aussi se trouve on se rappelle d'un
petit tirage de ligue des champions de
l'an dernier en huitièmes qu'on avait dû
refaire si elle a écouté on va c'est un
entraînement l'entraînement se fait par
des professionnels
le real de madrid qui va être retirées
je crois voilà dans le groupe f la semil
ans dans le groupe e donc ça a priori
donc le psg dans le groupe g et h donc
selon la boule qui va bientôt être tirée
bientôt du coup on barry knap rapidement
naples équipe on peut dire comme on dit
parfois en fin de cycle en
reconstruction en construction avec avec
l'ancien lillois aux emails en attaque
et qui est quand même très bon là ils
ont ils ont pris un joueur qui a marqué
trois buts
alors son nom je vais var à
kita là quelque chose comme ça je suis
vraiment désolé je vais mal le prononcer
mais donc enfin en tout cas ils ont il
va falloir voir s'ils gardent fabien
drouet ou si fabien ruiz vient renforcer
le paris saint-germain pour l'instant il
n'a pas été dans le groupe il a aidé al
toujours jouer il n'a toujours pas joué
cette saison sait rien donc
effectivement nous verrons alors que
nous avons gabriel garni keolis saluer
réel bonjour bonjour à vous ne vous
n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions à
réagir à ce tirage au sort et on voit là
vous le vivez vous les têtes de série
ont été tirées et c'est un peu
maintenant que ça va débuter on va voir
les normalement ce normand sait les deux
c'est le chapeau 2 qui va être tirée
vous le voyez un peu derrière nous le fc
barcelone n'a fini qu'au madrid fc
séville chelsea vais pas vous faire la
liste entière je vois requiem for a
dream qui est contre le football j'ai
l'impression qu'ils nous dit que voilà
on a toujours des gens qui sont bas sur
le figaro vous trouvez tout il ya du
sport il ya de l'international yann
l'économie vous n'êtes pas obligés de
regarder cela et s'il ne vous plaît pas
mais voilà excellent film excellent film
voilà en plus voilà vous y avait aussi
de la culture on veut aussi pour but
aussi par les filles effectivement mais
nous ne sommes pas là pour ça cédric
donc là nous avons la présentation des
différents clubs doublé à l'atletico la
chirurgie la juventus par exemple est-ce
que la juventus fait encore peur est ce
que c'est encore un gros club alors
honnêtement vous falloir voir ce qui va
se passer sur cette fin de mercato pour
l'instant je trouve que la juventus ne
fait pas peur ils ont perdu quand même
un certain nombre de joueurs
offensivement ils ont ils ont vu leurs
vitres qui a l'air d'être vraiment le
traître est un futur très grand et déjà
un très très grand attaquant mais
derrière bon il va falloir voir federico
kesa comment il revient de sa blessure
s'il revient au niveau qu'il avait avant
ça peut faire un duo quand même assez
explosif mais derrière ces deux là
franchement mo is king bon bah on a vu
au paris saint germain
il a été bon temps en temps mais enfin
c'est quand même pas un cador et puis
après je serais même pas vous citer les
autres attaquants qu'ils ont donc ils
ont pris dit maria qui en fin de course
offensivement ça m'a l'air très léger si
vous la au beach bon je touche du bois
pour lui mais messi se blessait ne
serait ce que deux mois parce qu'en plus
il va falloir voir que la petit détail
sur cette phase de groupe ça va être
intense ça va être ce neuf semaines
entre début septembre et début novembre
donc là les matches vont s'enchaîner la
moindre blessure vous êtes absent un
mois ou un mois et demi vous dites au
revoir à la phase de groupes déjà parce
qu'à une petite coupure exactement on
oublie pas entre novembre et décembre le
rb leipzig qui a été tirée en premier
league 6 ch qui va devoir aller l'onglet
club allemand iront dans les groupes e f
g h donc le psg à 50% de chance
actuellement d'attraper un groupe
allemand
puisque il y à dortmund et leipzig cinq
clubs allemands il me semble à 50 balais
brosses à leverkusen aussi je l'avais
oublié le bayer leverkusen
marseille avec ronaldo est favori oui
alors ça je ne suis pas entièrement
d'accord sur surtout ça favoris les
favoris de la ligue des champions
peut-être un peu compliqué on va falloir
acheter trois quatre autres joueurs
alors groupe f pour le pour les biches
bref voilà ça y est c'est ce qu'on
disait le real sait comment ça commence
à se dessiner on va avoir un groupe du
real à sa main tranquille à sa main
facile ou non pourrait pas c'est
compliqué de dire facile
meego est lui demande où est le barça
barça il va être tirée bientôt puisqu'il
est dans le chapeau 2 le barça il n'a
pas été champion parce qu'il faut être
champion pour être dans le chapeau 1 on
vous le rappelle là c'est un autre club
qui va être tirée ces êtres la juventus
du tout le monde en parle et agit dans
ceux de turin qui va tirer la juventus
de turin
donc pas lasser milan je ne sais pas si
ils peuvent déjà voilà donc là c'est
alors la juventus de turin je pense
qu'ils peuvent aller partout
apparemment ils ne peuvent aller que
dans le groupe g est dans le groupe h
parce que oui alors je ne sais toujours
pareil on donc 50% de chance pour le psg
d'ado trappe la juventus de turin on va
voir ce qui serait un bon tirage
ça reste un nom la juventus mais rien et
bien voilà c'est pour ces pour le psg
voilà la juventus de turin psg on le
disait et qui peut c'est plus compliqué
qu'avant pour le poste virtus il fera
quand même s'en méfier il faudra quand
même se méfier mais il faudra voir ce
qui va se passer comme comme je disais
sur cette fin de mercato déjà est-ce que
adrien ramio va rester ou pas bon j'ai
l'impression que la piste manchester
united c'est quand même bien mieux
refroidie défensivement ils ont quand
même perdu chiellini bons qu'ils étaient
certes enfin deux en fin de course mais
qui restera leader qui vont exactement
ils ont perdu de l'irt donc ils ont pris
bremer qui venait de boeck a pas fait un
long voyage puisqu'il y jouer au torino
donc qui est un brésilien est tout bon
je ne vais pas vous mentir je n'ai pas
vu énormément joué au torino encore va
falloir voir ce qui peut donner mais
défensivement pardon défensivement il ya
un doute
il va falloir voir la juge
je vous dis ça reste un nom mais là
aujourd'hui franchement ça doit pas
faire peur au paris saint germain donc
voilà c'est tottenham qui va être tiré
on voir tottenham ils peuvent tous
meilleurs groupes a b c d ou e puis qui
ne peuvent pas tomber avec manchester
city on vous le rappelle
alors attendez ils nous disent le retour
de rabiot parc des princes le retour de
di maria au parc des princes ah oui
c'est vrai qu'il a dit maria qui va
revenir enfin un vrai prince tout à fait
vrai ça va être menée sur une petite
séquence émotion a dit marion oui je
pense que sera bio je sais pas si
l'émotion sera si forte mais ni narnia
ou et di maria il ait quand même écrit
une page magnifique de l'histoire du psg
alors que tottenham est tombé avec
l'entracte francfort entracte francfort
tottenham comment ça commence à
ressembler un groupe intéressant pour le
pour marseille même si tottenham ça
reste on voit leur début de saison ça
reste quand même le club du tandem kane
sonne qui a été très bon il se sont bien
ils ont bien recruté cet été même si
pour l'instant au début de saison
finalement leur recrue etc il les laisse
sur le banc je pense à richarlyson en
france est tellement l'anglais qui devra
essayer de se relancer
bissouma ils ont ils ont pris des très
bons joueurs mais qui pour l'instant
n'utilise pas donc
ça sera pas simple mais bon
marseille pour faire plaisir à certains
certains autres marseille avec cristiano
ronaldo ça peut faire quelque chose dans
un groupe b avec liverpool qui vient
d'être tiré dans le groupe a ajax
d'amsterdam liverpool pareil voilà
plutôt à la portée de liverpool de ce
petit match en tout cas il va falloir
voir si l'ajax peut sortir des des
jeunes mais effectivement le pour la
pour liverpool c'est plutôt un bon
tirage
en plus bon certes iso pour l'instant
ils ont en début de saison assez assez
compliqué mais j'ai pas très inquiet il
ya quand même une stabilité dans
l'effectif
certes ils ont perdu banner mais ils ont
pris la ruine nuit est bon il a fait une
découverte de la première league rouge
rouge colère avec son expulsion et tout
mais je pense que ça va vite rentrer
dans l'ordre je pense que klopp même g20
indiquent tous a déjà dit qu il fallait
qu'ils se calment donc je pense que
liverpool va très très vite redresser la
tête
l'ajax devrait pas leur poser trop de
problèmes alors on vous demande un
pronostic pour psg julve sachant que
charles martel a déjà donné le sien 4-1
pour le psg cédric iphone os qui comme
ça là maintenant afin de donner un score
carrément europa au parc oui ça peut
ça peut ça peut faire ça ça peut à turin
ça sera sans doute plus compliqué mais
mais la juve actuelle défensivement il
ya moyen de puis surtout le psg actuel
il ya moyen de leur faire mal de leur
faire mal en attaque alors psg contre le
g12 première fois en c1 vous confirmez
on va moi je n'ai pas la réponse moi non
plus l'un d'eux tente comme ça vous
laisse chercher voilà c'est un hobby
d'activité dans le tchat on voulait
chercher et j'ai juive est-ce qu'on a
lorsqu'on a un souvenir d'un psg juin
moi j'en ai pas personnellement on
entrait dans l'histoire et son nom dans
l'histoire dans l'histoire qatari du psg
j'en ai pas j'en ai pas souvenir
maintenant après
dans l'histoire canal+ du psg avant
ça je ne saurais pas dire on regardera
on regardera n'hésitez pas le fc
barcelone qui vient d'être tiré on va
voir où va tomber le fc reçoit alors que
effectivement je crois que séville fc
est tirée entre temps pour moi witter
city c'est l'ifc bonne chère city voilà
on a déjà sur un petit groupe
la deuxième place est assez accessible
quand on a au cours d'un voile à bail en
bas on en parlait tout à l'heure on n'a
jamais été sur le point de vous dire que
si barcelone aller par exemple dans le
groupe de porto ces fameuses belles
affiches groupe chapeau un chapeau 2
pour l'instant finalement on n'avait pas
vraiment me psg juventus est bien là ça
y est on là bayern barcelone et puis bah
on parlait de retrouvailles di maria p g
bâle à lewandowski bayern de munich ça
va être quelque chose alors il ya quand
même un certain passif entre ces deux
équipes récemment je crois que l'an
dernier il est déjà dans le même groupe
et sur son graal heureux où ils se sont
jouées il se joue un second jouer assez
assez régulièrement une jambe je crois
que l'an dernier sont dans le même
groupe et le ils ont failli se sont fait
exploser dans une phase de poules dans
un dans un tableau final je crois que
c'était en 2020 ouais donc à vous ils se
sont fait exploser complètement à
l'époque voilà donc ça rappelle
peut-être des mauvais souvenirs pour le
fc barcelone oui ça c'est puis surtout
le bayern
ils ont perdu lewandowski mais bon là il
0 bochum c'est ça donc
ça a pas l'air de les avoir embêté
plus que ça alors que on attirait ac
milan contre le contre l'ac milan ou
chelsea chelsea milan qui favorise a
priori je dirais quand même celle ci je
pense que
vu vu leur parcours ces deux dernières
saisons en ligue des champions
leur recrutement qui est qui et qui est
plutôt assez intéressant sauf bon sur le
plan offensif ils ont pris que staline
mais ils ont quand même perdu lucas coup
et werner maintenant aussi bien de la
coupe werner les deux étaient un petit
peu
lukaku termine quand même meilleur
buteur de chelsea l'an dernier ouais
mais bon on sentait que le courant ne
passait plus werner il est alors cramer
non parce qu'il n'a pas l'âge d'être
cramé je suis encore jeune donc mais
mais en tout cas il était très mal parti
maintenant ils ont pris coulibaly
derrière c'est comme c'est quand même
très solide alors concours et là j'avoue
que 50 millions sur lui je bon pourquoi
pas maintenant c'est la folie mais mais
bon je n'ai pas de référence sur ce
joueur plus précise de là à penser qu'un
gros saint-émilion je sais pas on nous
verrons est donc le dernier groupe fc
porto contre l'atletico madrid un bon
tir elle pratique ou et l'atletico qui
paraît tirage pour le fc porto voilà
donc un groupe ouvert de ce côté là ni
au niveau du groupe b mal à tepco de
madrid en fait c'est ça pas bouger quoi
c'est un peu la même équipe que la
saison dernière je crois que le seul
recrutement majeurs qu'ils ont c'est un
latéral sur lesquels ils ont mis 20
millions d'euros mais que je pareil que
je ne connaissais que de nom
donc
ils ont perdu quand même luis suarez
appareils bon c'était plus tout jeune et
tout mais enfin ça c'était quand même un
leader après ils ont ils ont des jeunes
qui poussent ils ont le brésilien
matheus cunha qui va peut-être avoir un
peu plus de place pour pour s'imposer
joie au félix dont on avait annoncé
monts et merveilles et qui pour
l'instant fait quatre matches
fantastiques et puis disparaît pendant
six matches et puis revient pierre
disparaît donc si l'atlético de madrid
trouve une certaine régularité avec ces
jeunes ils peuvent être un sérieux
outsider
mais là aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu
une énigme quand même effectivement on
va voir alors pour l'instant si on avait
un petit groupe de la mort là
le groupe c vous mettez l'inter de milan
là dedans et puis et puis vous rajoutez
marseille et puis toute la canebière qui
d'une certaine façon pleurs à octobre et
se réjouit de voir venir vélodrome c3 c3
adversaires mais bon c'est fini pour les
huitièmes de finale waouh un exploit en
nombre on peut croire toujours à
l'exploit vous pouvez croire à un
exploit le problème c'est que là il leur
faudra il faudrait prendre au moins neuf
ou dix points donc il va falloir trop 4d
explorera donc ça ça commence à faire
beaucoup cette communiqué charles martel
qui dit merci pour cela il merci à vous
de nous suivre n'hésitez pas à continuer
à poser vos questions bayern barça
trésor qui nous dit berriane barça 7 à 2
oui on s'en rappelle matt de ce match
napoli le napoli qui n est retiré le
napoli alors j'ai pas regardé donc bon
ça peut pas dans le groupe et j'ai déjà
donc ça s'est réglé donc pas le pal psg
ceva le milan forcément à b et on va
voir on va tomber sur abc des du coup
retrouvé sur l'un des quatre premiers et
ben voilà déjà deuxième à jacques
spindler naples ajax liverpool naples
alors liverpool en tête naples et ajax
troisième place pour l'instant pour
l'instant oui avec peut-être quand même
un petit avantage pour naples a priori
qui a quand même peut-être même même si
on l'a dit c'est un club en
reconstruction qui a peut-être un petit
peu plus d'expérience et encore l'ajax
sûr c'est bien le problème de l'ajax
c'est vraiment de 2,7 fait dépouiller
quoi d'avoir d'avoir d'avoir encore
perdu
sur ces cinq titulaires ouais donc c'est
bon ils ont fait revenir berwin donc
mais qui reste sur une saison à
tottenham assez assez moyennes voire
même médiocre donc
je l'ajax paille c'est un petit peu une
énigme et on va voir on va voir ce
qu'ils sont capables de faire donc je
mettrais quand même peut-être naples 2
devant l'ajax alors on a salzbourg qui
entraînait tyran voir dans quel club va
tomber salzbourg salzbourg ce toujours
pareil si une équipe de jeunes qui peut
toujours poser des soucis on l'a vu l'an
dernier avec l'âge on les connaît pas
vraiment enfin les connais pas vraiment
on n'est pas sur l'un des cinq jours
l'un des cinq grands championnats mais
par contre il ya des jeunes ça court
vite et c'est une belle vie
d'information ouais c'est une belle
belle équipe pour former les jeunes
alors ils ont déjà perdu à payer me qui
avait été brillant contre lille donc là
ils sont avec milan et chelsea
ça risque quand même d'être compliqué
faut voir s'ils arrivent encore à
ressortir quelques jeunes et tous
je pense que ça va être ça va quand même
être compliqué pour cette saison il
avait il avait sloboda aussi simple aux
side donc qui est parti donc alors je
crois qu'il est parti l'an dernier déjà
non il me semble qu'il n'était plus là
déjà la saison dernière qui était déjà
pu la saison dernière mais je veux pas
dire de bêtises je veux être mais je
crois qu'ils étaient déjà partis en
dernier alors je viens j'ai raté
l'équipe qui vient d'être tiré mais ce
n'est pas grave oui c'est benfica
benchikha qui vient d'être tiré le club
dans la communauté portugaise en plus
ils peuvent pas être dans le groupe
hé bé déjà donc pour la communauté
portugaise delà de l'île de france
groupe h c'est avec paris et ben voilà
il suffisait de le demander c'est un
troisième cas c'est fort benfica quand
même non alors c'est
une boîte en bout de ligne ter c'est une
équipe qui
sera dure à dur à jouer alors ils ont
perdu darwin lyonnaise qui signa à
liverpool mais ils ont l'air d'avoir
tout de suite
trouver son successeur avec gonçalo
ramos qui est un attaquant plutôt
costaud
qui a l'air bon en tout cas qu'il a lors
des matches de qualification a mis un
triplé donc derrière il ya de
l'expérience parce qu'ils ont toujours
l'achat ils ont vertonghen et otamendi
même s'il ya morato qui a l'air d'être
bien partie un jaune pour le défenseur
portugais claire des bien parti pour ont
déboulonné un des deux anciens
ça va être ça va être intéressant alors
on parle de retrouvailles parce qu'il y
avait quand même bayern fc barcelone
mais là on a quand même un match star
city borussia dortmund le à l'andi coups
bas exactement et donc ses îles et
coquin ce tirage là donc pour à londres
ça va être pareil à un moment assez
assez assez spécial c'est particulier de
se retrouver face au mur enfin du mur de
dortmund qui là qu'il a tant célébrés
qui l'attend portait donc
là ça va être intéressant parce que le
borussia ç'a toujours été une équipe qui
joue alors bon malheureusement ils ont
recruté à l'air qui qui a eu son gros
soucis de santé on lui souhaite vraiment
le
le plus pro le meilleur rétablissement
possible ils ont pris le français
anthony modeste à la place bon c'est
anthony modeste c'est un buteur à la
fois sous-estimé parce que c'est quand
même quelqu'un qui met régulièrement 10
15 buts en bundesliga
maintenant est-ce qu'il a le niveau
ligue des champions non on va on va vite
être fixé on rappelle que allaire avait
réussi très rapidement à s'intégrer à
marquer beaucoup de buts à l'ajax sur
les premières journées l'an dernier en
ligue des champions bayer leverkusen fc
porto atletico de madrid 13 ouvert comme
groupe très ouvert est-ce qu'on n'est
pas sur le faire deux groupes en bois
non quand même pas parce qu'on est on
est on est on est sûr sûr sûr quand même
des noms pour l'instant j'attends de
voir j'attends de voir par exemple ce
qui va voir ce qui va arriver dans le
groupe d qui et qui sait qu'ils restent
là si vous mettez dans le groupe d les
alors attention je veux pas être méchant
avec avec aucun club mais voilà j'allais
dire le sporting portugal ou donesk là
le groupe d vous commencez à ça
ressemble un peu à un groupe en bo1 je
vois pas ce qui pourrait arriver dans le
groupe 4 par contre c
pour marseille c'est bonjour c'est là
c'est parce qu'ils voulaient espérer les
huitièmes de finale c'est là
il ya le groupe s'est toujours
d'épouvantail mais on rappelle c'est
soit groupes a b c ou d hélas les trois
groupes il reste alors il reste l'inter
de milan l'inter de milan dans le groupe
c là ça devient sexy là on aurait notre
groupe de la borne à chaque ardennais ce
qui va être retirée on va voir où vont
tomber chaque heure de desk bas groupe f
où c'est donc il n'y a plus que deux
choix et je vous rappelle ce que j'avais
aujourd'hui chaque alors avec chaque
tiers donneur soit dans le groupe f ce
groupe c chaque sur ray lema le real de
madrid c'est parti c'est encore cadeau
c'est à se demander alors on parlait
souvent de la chance de didier deschamps
sur les sur les tirages au sort si vous
voulez l'équivalent de didier deschamps
en club vous prenez c'est le real de
madrid alors j'ai une petite stat pour
vous ça fait trois fois d'affilée que le
shaktar donesk tombe avec le real de
madrid ben merci pour la loi
parce que parce qu'en fait ça faisait
deux ans qu'il était tombé avec l'inter
de milan real madrid l'inter de milan
shaktar donesk l'an dernier et ya deux
ans hélas cette année de l'inter de
milan sera donc avec le bayern munich le
fc barcelone ça ça va être ça va être ça
va être ça va être extraordinaire ça ce
groupe-là l'a déjà vous avez le groupe
de la mort est là c'est sûr mais alors
donc on vous rappelle la marseille va
aller dans le groupe a b c ou d
évidemment
alors évidemment il y en a un est vite
et on a trois groupes abordable ce qui
permettent de croire à la qualification
il ya un groupe très abordable groupe d
il ya un groupe spectacle où c'est la
folie au vélodrome pour trois soirs
voilà donc mais mais je suis pas sûr que
si vous voulez faire venir cristiano
cristiano ronaldo et vouloir
ça me ferait des beaux matches à jouer
ça lui serait des beaux matches à jouer
mais je pense qu'il y en a joué
suffisamment ladder plus toujours on
dise de cristiano qu'aujourd'hui ce qui
l'intéresse ses stats et demain je pas
sûr que de se retrouver dans le groupe
c'est va lui permettre d'augmenter
considérablement son nombre de buts
marqués par contre dans le groupe d
après ce qu ils voudraient ce qu'il ira
à marseille si marseille joue contre le
sporting portugal ça c'est encore une
autre question
alors j'ai eu le chat sous les yeux je
vais demander à sony à ludovic de
continuer à se vanner entre un
marseillais est un supporter du psg donc
on peut se gagner mais de façon cordiale
bien sûr on peut continuer n'y a pas de
souci mais il faut être sympa et
bienveillant les uns vers les autres on
a actuellement la présentation des
groupes des équipes pardon du chapeau 4
donc on va voir un peu ce qui s'est
passé là clairement on est sur le groupe
c et groupe de la mort et groupe d le
groupe le plus simple voilà après le
groupe c'est peut être encore plus le
groupe de la mort si vous mettez donc
marseille ou si vous mettez peut-être
les glasgow rangers sous le celtic de
glasgow qui sont peut-être aussi de
serre y en a deux sérieux clients et le
groupe d toujours c'est toujours pas
forcément gentil de dire ça mais si vous
mettez
les tchèques de plzen ou le maccabi
haifa là vous avez quand même un groupe
qui en terme d'audience à la télé ça va
pas ça va pas faire rêver quoi va pas
faire et effectivement on verra donc ce
qui va se passer alors les les équipes
du quai du catherine gaud sont en train
d'être tirées hector qui j'espère que
l'om sera dans le groupe c on va voir
s'ils voulaient des belles affiches
après ça dépend si il ya toujours 50
mille façons de voir un tirage chez vous
estimez que marseille de toute façon
dans sa course dans sa configuration
actuelle n'a pas le niveau pour aller en
huitièmes y compris même si vous les
mettez dans le groupe b dans le groupe à
où dans le groupe d enfin dans ce cas là
autant les mettre dans le groupe c et
puis et puis avoir avoir que des
affiches de rêve face à des traits
blancs creux très grand club pardon
l'inter de milan s'était quand même le
champion d'italie il ya des élèves de
saison et des saisons ça reste encore
une très très grosse équipe ils ont pris
lukaku est il lothar au martinez y
lumbroso beach au milieu de terrain ils
ont vont t'ils de garder jusqu'à la fin
du mercato ils ont toujours ce crinière
derrière de vrij handanovic au but ça
c'est que dénoncer son équipe c'est une
équipe qui veut pas dire qu'il fait
rêver on va peut-être pas exagérer non
plus enfin c'est très très très solide
alors que le celtic glasgow viennent
tirer real madrid's la vie si je bosse
sur l'escaut moins dans le groupe 4 ils
n'ont pas pris le plus simple voilà au
moins un moment on est sur une équipe un
peu plus compliqué on va dire mais c'est
surtout au là bas c'est toujours dans
cette dans cette ambiance écossaise qui
est juste exceptionnelle à glasgow mais
à montréal le real il ya quand même de
vrais de vrais tranquillement finir
premiers de ce groupe f je vois pas je
vois pas même si ça peut leur arriver
dès fois en phase de groupe ils
s'étaient faits sheriff tiraspol qui les
avait perdus je crois l'olympique de
marseille vient tirer ça on va enfin
savoir contre qui va sauver on reparle
l'olympique de marseille groupes a b c d
je ne crois pas que ce soit encore tiré
on a pas on n'a pas encore là moi je moi
je ne l'est pas peut-être que vous le
voyez mieux sur l'écran mais moi non
ces notions flammes mais au-dessus est
du jour d'optique et asnières ginter qui
est en train de tirer c'est aussi le
groupe d et voilà pourquoi et bien
écoutez marseille là peut franchement
s'il deuxième du championnat de france
n'a pas son mot à dire face par exemple
au sporting portugal qui qui a quand
même perdu pareil c'est au milieu de
terrain ils ont par ailleurs ils ont
perdu ma été matée husnu nièce qui a
signé à wolverhampton et pas lignac a
signé à fulham donc ils ont des jeunes
et tous les ans fin c'est quand même pas
c'est quand même pas un épouvantail line
trike frankfort aux caisses à gagner la
ligue europa c'est la bonne équipe c'est
dire donc c'est pas c'est pas un joueur
mon tottenham sera le favori logique de
ce groupe mai mai marseille doit pouvoir
doit pouvoir faire quelque chose face à
francfort et sporting enfin il faut il
faut espérer il faut espérer en tout cas
qu'ils vont augmenter un peu lent
moyenne de points on vous rappelle les
deux dernières campagnes de l'om c'est
trois points sur 36 possibles las ils
prennent que trois points dans ce groupe
là
ça commence à
quelque chose d'un peu compliqué si vous
et puis un bon début de saison
finalement pour l'olympique de marseille
un bon début de saison alors bon on a
appris le départ de milic qui est de mon
point de vue quelque chose de totalement
incompréhensible parce que parce que
parce que franchement dans cette équipe
il y avait moyen de le faire briller
donc
ça c'est une vraie déception maintenant
il va falloir voir ce que ce que
marseille est capable de faire sur cette
fin de mercato voilà toujours parler de
cristiano ronaldo
d'après les rumeurs qu'on a en tout cas
si ronaldo veut jouer la ligue des
champions ce serait dans le groupe d
puisque si soit il veut revenir au
sporting au sporting portugal soit il va
à marseille tellement de bonnes raisons
d'aller et de venir à marseille
finalement alors groupe g moudjar city
séville borussia dormund le fc
copenhague qui a fait retirer alors là
on va peut-être pas faire aussi long sur
les équipes tirées dans le groupe 4 sauf
si c'est vrai que vous êtes un
spécialiste du championnat danois
écouter sur copenhague je vais jouer je
vais je vais passer la main je pense que
je pense que
malheureusement
pour mais même pour aller essayer de
choper la troisième place pour seront
reversés en ligue europa ça risque
d'être difficile pour copenhague dans un
tel groupe donc
là a priori on a city au dessus
dortmund séville pour la deuxième place
à seulement on va rien inventer là
dessus le groupe b bruges qui tombe le
fc porto aly dicko madrid bayer
leverkusen là on est aussi sur un groupe
ouvert est-ce que bruges peut faire un
petit truc peuvent toujours espérer vie
porto s'est alors là on est bon on va
pas dire un groupement bois parce que
parce que l'atlético de madrid quand
même et puis porto ça reste des noms qui
parlent ça reste des équipes qui vont
souvent huitième on car la ccico de
madrid ils ont même été en
finale donc et porto aussi mais il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
longtemps donc là on est on est quand
même sur des sur des noms aux prêts
aujourd'hui à aucune de ces équipes ne
présente de garantie bayer leverkusen
vient de commencer la bundesliga de
façon merveilleuse avec trois défaites
en trois matches
donc porto se reconstruit l'atlético de
madrid a quasiment pas recruter donc
pourquoi pas pour bruges on avait vu la
saison dernière dans le groupe du psg
il avait pris une ou deux claques mais
il avait aussi fait quelques quelques
bonnes performances ils ont appris la
saison dernière peut-être faire un petit
un petit quelque chose oui groupe à
glasgow rangers snap une à liverpool à
amsterdam rogers là on a un groupe peu
un groupe sympa comme liverpool est au
dessus et en dessous il ya quand même
trois écoutes tout est très ouvert là
derrière et puis on a des gros plans
l'appareil on a des grands noms du
football donc
puis glasgow rangers pour leur retour
pour la ligue des champions en ligue des
champions 12 ans 12 ans après c'est
quand même sympa comme groupe
un petit ranger ce liverpool franchement
ça c'est non ça c'est une simple petite
saveur de football comme on aime ça peut
être sympa à les voir en écosse un match
comme ça je pense ça pue ça peut être
sympa à voir handfield aussi
effectivement donc on va voir alors là
et c'est un autre club qui attire et je
n'ai pas vu qu'elle était le club il
reste beaucoup l'attention reste maccabi
haifa dizaine déjà pour paris ça
commence à sentir très bon et le
troisième qui manque c'est le dinamo
zagreb comme je l'avais dit de toute
façon le psg avait pas grand chose à
craindre de ce chapeau 4 l'a priori il
reste les
pas loin d'être les trois plus faibles
et enfin peut-être copenhague en dessous
du dinamo de zagreb mai
dix ans plus l'ignorer vient de sortir
dans le groupe e donc écouter pour le
psg on peut je pense qu'on peut parler
d'eux pour moi c'est un peu un tirage à
l'image du psg dont on disait c'est pas
c'est pas le groupe le plus simple c'est
pas le groupe du real de madrid
mais mais c'est un groupe abordable
si la juge fait pas des étincelles sur
les je n'ai pas l'impression que la juge
va faire des étincelles sur le marché
des transferts sur ces cinq six derniers
jours
franchement le psg est très nettement
favori pour finir premiers de ce groupe
effectivement voir maccabi haïfa qui
l'attiré on va voir de quel côté va
tomber mais je sais c'est marrant ça
ferait des souvenirs aussi
occasion de prendre une revanche
tranquille de leur élimination coupe des
coupes
ça pourrait être sympa ça ferait ça aura
une histoire un peu plus a raconté que
que plus zen pour nous journalistes ou
la turia une dizaine se lance on pense
on pense que ça se prononce lizaine si
on a des amis tchèques qui sont là bas
voilà paris ça sera ma came l'ifa donc
nous les ont donc écouté pour paris oui
c'est un peu un peu la thématique parce
que en plus il y aura les retrouvailles
avec di maria et avec radio
pour la communauté portugaise
d'ile-de-france benfica c'est sympa
la communauté israélienne aussi mac à
baillif à tous tout ça c'est un groupe
très sympathique saint germain est donc
le viktoria pilsen qui va découler du
groupe c les pauvres banon alors pour
eux pour eux de toute façon les
huitièmes de finale 7 est inabordable
donc j'ai presque envie de dire que
c'est bien parce que oui moi ils vont se
régaler enfin le le public tchèque va
avoir trois affiches exceptionnelles de
toute façon
même dans un autre groupe il n'aurait
pas pu viser les huitièmes de finale il
aura peut-être effectivement pu viser la
troisième place pour essayer d'être
reversé en ligue europa
mais non pour eux c'est bien par contre
enfin c'est bien après il va falloir en
espérant qu'ils s'en prennent pas 6 et 7
pour le bayern il faut voir il faut voir
effectivement que ça tourne pas en
déroute et en démonstration ce qui est
possible après on l'a vu aussi avec le
psg pourrait aussi en caux.les
quelques-uns au maccabi haïfa parce
qu'ils sont originaires de s'énerver
depuis les saisons ils ont l'air énervé
et puis le maccabi haïfa on a vu lors de
lord et notamment du barrage contre le
l'étoile rouge de belgrade que ça fait 3
2 2 donc on a vu que le maccabi haïfa en
attaque ça de cette dette un peu sérieux
mais en défense ils ont même perdu 2-0
je crois à chypre donc
haifa en défense a pas l'air ça pas
l'air la sécurité sociale donc
effectivement ça pourrait
ça pourrait faire beaucoup quoi alors on
va voir ce que donne et on va vite fait
parler des différents groupes groupe a
ajax liverpool naples rangers on a dit
liverpool tout en haut et les trois
autres peuples se jouer entre la
deuxième place tout à fait groupe b
portois les dicos madrid leverkusen club
brugge un groupe ouvert qu'il favori
dans ce groupe
oui l'atletico 2 par deux pas de par son
passé de par son statut
de par son effectif quand même il reste
bon ben si griezmann en ce moment on en
a quand même un doute mais il ya quand
même des des bonnes ondes en cette
équipe assez solide il ya toujours
négocié mes hommes qui avec un
entraîneur charismatique qui est capable
de sublimer son équipe il ya thomas
lebas il ya des français
oui quand-même l'atletico mais bon ce
sera simple bayern munich fc barcelone
et inter milan viktoria pilzen le groupe
de la mort le groupe de la mort avec moi
a priori sur ce qu'ils montrent depuis
le début de la saison comme peut-être le
bayern un petit peu favori mais bon
comme on l'a dit barça a fait un
recrutement très très fort maintenant si
l'allemagne mayonnaise prend avec sa vie
comme entraîneur ça peut faire très très
mal peut-être un petit doute
défensivement quand même là les
concernant surtout face au bayern
bon on va pas rappeler qu'ils en avaient
pris 7 mais je pense qu'à l'époque
défensivement ils étaient plus solides
qu'ils ne le sont aujourd'hui
et puis la ligne ter qui sera prendre
très au sérieux et qui qui fait pas
figure de victime expiatoire dans ce
groupe c groupe d le groupe de marseille
on l'a dit un groupe plutôt ouvert sur
lequel marseille pourrait tout peut
croire aux huitièmes de finale
logiquement tottenham devrait devrait
finir premier je pense qu'ils sont a
priori au dessus et derrière derrière
bon francfort qui a gagné la ligue
europa la saison dernière mais
tout est faisable pour la deuxième place
effectivement groupe e milan chelsea
salzbourg zagreb c'est qu'il favori de
ce groupe merci aussi pour moi je sais
chelsea milan milan il faut il faut voir
ils ont été les champions d'italie est
où maintenant ils ont quand même un
effectif assez jeune ils ont une
charnière centrale plein d'avenir avec
ton maury et le français kalulu qu'elle
lui je ne j'ai toujours un doute sur la
prononciation mais ils vont découvrir la
ligue des champions ce niveau là ton
mojito maury qui était un ancien de
chelsea je sais pas s'il avait joué
quelques matches avec chelsea je crois
qu'il était un peu cantonné sur le banc
de touche à l'époque donc donc en terme
de
d'expérience il va falloir voir mais je
pense que celle ci devrait être au
dessus le groupe f j'avais un
commentaire justement qui en parler le
réel est encore dans un bon groupe on le
disait de son vernis sont vernis sont
voilà c'est même pas il sait même pas
qu'ils sont favoris et c'est que après
il ya toujours vous n'êtes pas là et si
ça peut les embêter un peu quand même
ouais encore je suis même pas sûr c'est
le sheriff tiraspol an dernier oui oui
voilà ils peuvent se faire surprendre
sur un match pourquoi pas messieurs sur
sur un petit championnat sur franchement
je pense que le real a suffisamment
d'expérience ont certes ils ont perdu
kazemi roman fins et tous à peu près la
même équipe que l'année dernière ils ont
pris une fois mais ni ils ont rüdiger
derrière
ça ça me semble hyper solide jeu il ya
toujours la glorieuse incertitude du
sport mais la très incertaine
dans la qualif elle est certaine un peu
au palais peut être imaginé un tout
petit doute sur la première place est
encore groupe g j'avais un autre alors
j'ai perdu son nom qui me disait le sait
pas le groupe de la mort parce que c'est
le groupe c'est sûr mais groupe g c'est
solide aussi ses solides wallace est
solide
il semble enfin avoir donc ce que
comment dortmund ger l'absence dallaire
et voir un peu ce que modeste peut faire
le fc séville ça reste toujours une
équipe qui qui qui qui est toujours là
bon casse plus brillé en ligue europa
cre qu'en ligue des champions mais
qui pourrait finir troisième occupant la
traversée en ligue europa était de
briller encore en ligue europa et puis
bon vous avez su city qui devrait quand
même être au dessus mais qui va devoir
s'employer alors il après avec city font
toujours voir un petit peu
c'est jamais évident de lire dans les
compose de guardiola qui peut faire
tourner alors des fois il s'est tourné
en première league pas en ligue des
champions et ce qui est bon
mais on va répondre surtout surveiller
des retrouvailles à londres par contre
effectivement le alors dit qu on va
appeler ça comme ça groupe h le dernier
avec paris charles martel qui me dit
paris aura un peu de tact dans son
groupe malgré tout aura un peu de
travail un peu de
oui il y aura du travail parce que la
juve et benfica s'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas gagné mais
normalement normalement au parc je pense
qu'il ya quand même largement les moyens
de faire carton plein à gagner à riffa
d'aller faire un résultat benfica dans
ces cas là
casio fait littéralement voilà après
même si même s'il ya turin c'est un peu
plus compliqué logiquement pas de soucis
puis surtout on voit le psg actuel
alors certes je pense qu'ils vont pas
jouer tout le temps comme ils l'ont fait
contre lille ça sera pas toujours aussi
lembeye ans florian cristallin d'une
pureté technique et tout comme ça mais
après il va falloir voir la gestion de
l'effectif comme on le disait en début
de ce live il faut rappeler donc avec la
petite coupe du monde qui nous attend à
partir de mi novembre
ça va être très resserrée donc en
général c'était plutôt le cette phase de
groupes étaient plutôt sur deux mois
deux mois et une ou deux semaines là ça
va être ça va être vraiment très très
très court enfin jeudi deux mois non
c'était plutôt trois mois par donc trois
mois pour cette phase pour cette phase
de groupes donc là la moindre blessure
d'un mois d'un mois et demi et vous
loupé quatre matches n'ont pas deux
comme comme ça pouvait arriver
effectivement alors une dernière
question quand même c'est parce qu'on a
eu pas mal de questions sur ça c'est un
peu le pronostic pour cette ligue des
champions qui est le favori des
champions allez on vend
est ce qu'on peut en avoir 3 est ce
qu'on peut avoir leur entrée 3 on va
trois là vous gâter vincent vaut mieux
était alors 3 bat a priori moi je dirais
le paris saint germain je dirais
manchester city
prêt alors il s'est toujours bon c'est
un instantané quand on voit ce que fait
le bayen dans ce début de saison j'avoue
que je suis assez assez bluffé je suis
curieux de voir ce qu'elle va faire
barça
liverpool va se réveiller j'en suis
certain mais bon on va dire p
gpg city et le bayern allez on rappelle
effectivement que c'est pas maintenant
qu'il faut être bon c'est au mois
d'avril
il faut pas avoir les avoir les
blessures au mauvais moment il faut au
moyen des effectifs qui sont plus
profonds que d'autres je vais être
beaucoup le real en 8e en février faute
a priori si tout va bien a vu des
groupes il y aura pas
lampard était gérée alors 8e normalement
mais
ou alors c'est que le psg à mr douillet
en phase de groupes on verra ça merci en
tout cas cédric d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous merci à vous d'avoir été
très nombreux à nous suivre je remercie
renan luce blaise qui étaient avec nous
en régie je remercie également maxime
laurie qui nous a aidé pour ce live et
moi je vous dis à bientôt pour de
nouveaux lives sur figaro l'oeil